Los Angeles Wednesday December 14th I am
shooting my special at the dynasty
typewriter theater the first show is
sold out thank you so much there are
very few tickets left for the second
show get them now use code sickler at
checkout you're gonna get half off your
tickets thank you so much come on out
Let's Zone both out have some fun I'll
be there shooting my first special
you'll be a part of it I can't thank you
all enough
[Music]
Grand Rapids Michigan I'll be there
December 9th and 10th get your tickets
for those shows on my website at
ryansickler.com
[Music]
the Honeydew with Brian sickler
[Applause]
welcome back to the Honeydew y'all we're
over here doing it in the night pants
Studios I'm Ryan
sicklerionsickler.com Ryan sickler on
all your social media and as I always
say thank you thank you for your support
thank you for the love thank you for the
messages it means the world if you are
watching this please hit that damn
subscribe button y'all just hit it it
helps the show tremendously and if you
gotta have more then you gotta check out
the patreon I will preach it every week
it is the Honeydew with y'all where I'm
highlighting the low lights with y'all
and nobody's got stories like y'all it's
the wildest show on patreon it's five
bucks a month you sign up for a year you
get over a month free and you get the
Honeydew a day early you get it ad free
you get it at no additional cost all
right if you or someone you know has
that story it has to be heard please
submit it to honeydew podcast gmail.com
and hopefully we get to do an episode
together all right if you guys are in
town when I'm on tour come on out and
see me Chicago November 11th and 12th
and Grand Rapids December 9th and 10th
now that's the biz you guys know what we
do over here we highlight the low lights
I always say these are the stories
behind the storytellers today very
excited to have this guest here first
time on the Honeydew ladies and
Gentlemen please welcome Nick Simmons
welcome to the Honeydew Nick
thanks
thank you for doing my club also you can
bro you can all right some people clap
for themselves I'm a big fan of people
clapping themselves I think I'm the
opposite I go all right all right settle
down I did uh I did Todd glasses podcast
years ago and and
he's so all over his style but you'll do
15 or 20 minutes and he's like okay now
we're gonna introduce you I'm like wait
we're doing the introduction yeah so he
goes and you have two choices I heard
Diaz does that too you could sit here
and you can um just be introduced like
this or and he used to record where
there was these stairs up here and he
had a band a little band in there yeah
in the small room like with this and he
goes or you can be played in on standby
yeah just right here just he pays them
just to they played yeah and I was like
I can be played in right now and that
Tosh point no money's really I was like
bro play me in man I did love his
terrible prank show you ever see that
time glasses terrible prank show and
nobody laughs and he's like ha ha you
know your baby's dead or whatever the
[ __ ] he was doing and people were like
why would you do this Todd Glass is
terrible pranks
uh well before we get into your stories
today please plug promote everything you
want I literally can't um but I can I'll
go to I'm on social Nick T Simmons is my
uh Instagram I'm pretty much down there
exclusively but I literally can't I'm uh
I've been releasing stuff and doing
stuff under uh a couple pseudonyms for
the past like four or five years is that
right and so it's out there I'm just not
ready to be under me yet but uh if you
follow me I'll eventually talk about it
but yeah it's
it's going really well and I really like
that nobody knows it's me so so you have
something going on it's already out and
it's been happening and it's been
happening and no one knows no one knows
it's been real but it's good it's uh if
you stand up Batman bro
stand up no I would never do Stan don't
worry I'm not gonna do stand up
you can all relax it's not happening
okay well great then fine but yeah just
follow me I'll I'll post it I'll maybe
I'll call you back and see if you'll
help me back on at some point if you of
course like me after today all right
um well first of all thank you for being
here I recently met you
um I had no idea you were even a fan or
anything and you'd even say you've been
to my that's crazy thank you since the
since the top for all of you guys all
the uh ymh and extended families for
since like early microphone on the couch
days that's crazy dude that's wild to me
and
you're like I've been to your stand-up
shows I'm like how did I miss how tall
are you well I'm sitting yeah but still
you get up I'm all I'm all leg when I
sit down it's all are you six what six
six eight how the [ __ ] did I ever miss
you
uh you know what I heard I heard that
Trump's youngest kid is my height is
that the weirdest thing right Karen the
kid and he has like a baby face isn't he
six eight
already apparently [ __ ] it's it's
alarming
because he's still got like a baby face
a child six eight child yeah very
strange anyway
um well it was great to meet you and and
you know like I don't know I I said to
you before you got to be tired of
talking about your dad but I I just
wanna I do want to say something about
your dad so I I got to meet him because
of you thank you very much because that
is
you know I grew up in that era and I got
to see your dad when they put the makeup
back on in Madison Square Garden and I'm
like oh my God I'm gonna get the 99
something like that yeah right around
there it might have been before was it
99 99 I remember there was like a
Halloween show they did in makeup with
Ace and Peter I think at Madison Square
Garden I think that might have been part
of that tour 311 got booed off stage it
was great it was great this was I was in
college this had to be nice what
festival was this it wasn't it was just
kiss is putting the makeup back on and
311's opening I think they kicked the
tour off in Madison Square Garden that
when they first put the makeup back on
and I was like I don't know if I
remember oh Madison Square probably
wasn't there so we drove up from
Baltimore to watch and um this isn't the
time you got a concussion right no man
that's that was the Eagles if that was
my I should have got my ass if that was
my dad's fault I was about to feel real
bad I know that story really well it was
actually no
um it was dad's tour bus backed over you
this was a great [ __ ] uh it was a
great concert to see that but
he comes in and he's he's complimenting
me
you know and then he's asking me about
my [ __ ] writing process Street jokes
about you no Street jokes he did one he
did one it was great he goes Ryan it was
a great well he goes what is what's 10
inches in Jewish uh and I I go what he
goes nothing
[Laughter]
not as bad he he launched I talked to
Tom I talked to Segura about this like
two days ago and he was like
yeah dads are always Just Dads huh like
he was like he reminds me of my like top
dog he reminds me of right and I was
like he didn't do Street jokes to he
goes He launched immediately into like
five Street jokes immediately because he
thinks that's what Tom goes he thinks
that's what I do for a living he thinks
that that's could you imagine that you
walked up to him and just started
singing songs or something
I think they have but
but like that's a certain generation's
idea of stand up they think hey she's
abroad she's a Dame knock knock you know
it's take my wife please [ __ ] too and
and I it just blew my mind because all I
could say I call my friend and I'm like
you don't even know he's like what I go
Gene Simmons comes up to me last night
and he's talking to me about my process
and I'm like are you talking to me about
my creative process right now and your
dad's like yeah and I was like
I was you for Halloween for two years
that's all I could say how did you
noticed that about musicians and
comedians I feel like musicians are all
fascinated by Comedians and vice versa
Dean Del Rey just told me about this Bon
Scott tribute he does every year and
it's going to happen this month I guess
they're all like it's a it's this weird
cross genre looking over the fence at
each other admiration thing that I've
noticed like every musician I know is
like a massive you know loves Burr and
all these guys well I love hearing like
the musicians are out on the road
listening because they're I get it
you're tired of music so you're over
here listening to comedians I'm tired of
listening to comedians listening to
music you know all my friends who are in
studio like my sister is a top liner she
writes for herself but she also writes
for other people she writes like pop
songs for people because pop stars can't
write for [ __ ] and so she uh she says
like you know after a long day the
studio you want to listen to like maybe
classical or talk like you don't want to
hear like yet another curse sorry chorus
versus right it's just your brain gets
fried so for an afternoon I find the
same thing when I was jamming around
town you get burnt a little bit I've I
find comedians too like they're like I
don't want to watch my friends set I
just I had to go because I don't want to
like poach material or I don't want to
like get influenced and it gives me
anxiety because I remember what bombings
like if they don't do well it's like
there's a weird yeah and I know a lot of
businesses are like I could never do
that about comedy because it's there's
no backup there's no like bassist if you
[ __ ] up there's no basis kind of caring
yeah it's just you and your your mouth
yeah terrifying that's I don't mind
public speaking I couldn't do stand-up
that's horrifying to me yeah as big of a
fan as you are you don't think you can
I'm content being a family totally
content I don't want to do it I like
hearing that to be honest with you
everyone in L.A wants to do everything
yeah I could do that no you [ __ ]
can't stop you could do it bad yeah
everyone could do it yeah all right so
let's talk about you because
um
you know I was thinking about this have
you ever considered the amount of loads
your father shot out of his dick
and the billions of sperm that must have
gone
I expected this from Christina
expected
you turned into a human see I expected
this your odds are you're listen your
dad [ __ ] way more than my dad I feel
like cigar is about to pop in and say
I've been punked this is this is clear
why a mage Vibes what's coming out of
your mouth right now I thought about it
like Jesus Christ the odds of you
turning into life
Hey listen you know ours is way less
than a regular person you don't know
that that's just on record as talking
about it every other Dad could be in
Cabo
me there's a couple other dudes it still
counts if they're not like hot enough to
brag about it
if they didn't tell you the story he
still did it you don't know it's a lot
of loads I gotta imagine it's awesome
yeah keep saying that that's cool
keep saying it over and over again it's
fine it's already saying it once it's
the same as saying it twice it's the
odds are rebellions billions I mean I
think each load is like trillions so I
mean technically it's quintillion you
made it out here on this rock in outer
space how about I know for you I beat
the Nobel Prize guy crazy about this
your odds are crazy yeah okay okay so
you're gonna do the swimming like it was
a pretty Auto I know he shot it but
still still you you missed your
opportunity at a love gun joke there and
I I'm really disappointed I'm
disappointed what if your dad makes us
take this out
well he can't and yeah I read an article
once for vice called my dad's full of
[ __ ] you can't yeah he didn't take that
down so I think he'll be fine he didn't
no I'll go it was a loving Father's Day
article at the end it was just a funny
title
um all right you're born into this life
uh your dad's Gene Simmons your mom
Shannon Tweed your sister's older or
younger younger three years younger and
it's just the two of you yeah
what age do you realize this isn't
[ __ ] what everyone else is doing well
actually it's um
I don't really know because I uh I went
to public school until about ninth grade
is that right just normal yeah
um
yeah I went to Warner Avenue and then
Emerson Middle School for a little while
and then uh Emerson I didn't like it
like I didn't really get I was like you
know nerdy artistic kid and it was like
people were like you're a jocker you're
a loser basically kind of like typical
American High School Vibes there so then
I went to like I totally switched gears
and went to this like super
liberal you know kind of private school
not like uniform formals very like
hippie casual but there was like tons of
other Sons and Daughters of people there
so you would think like oh we'd all
become you know ego monsters in that
place but actually it had the kind of
had the opposite effect because if you
bring it up
needlessly you're like that kid it's
like yeah we all have shut up like
you're so it was kind of like this weird
Level Playing Field where like you're
not going to bring it up because Eddie
Murphy's daughter is next to you so like
you're not gonna like did you know that
my dad it's like then they'd be like
yeah we all have that shut up like
you're not special so nobody talked
about it we just acted my dad's John
Oates man ain't nobody over here oh my
God and you know when I didn't think
about it at the time like at the time
you just don't think about it they're
just your friends at school yeah but
after I went to college I was like wait
a second so we had I grew up with Cooper
Hefner uh
uh I'm uh let's see uh I did uh Georgia
Ford was my classmate Harrison Ford's
daughter okay uh two of Eddie Murphy's
children uh the Willis children were in
jazz band with me like one of them was
uh and so and like Ashton Kutcher used
to pick her up from school
but like so if you start talking you're
just well then you're just like that guy
he's like all right so settle the [ __ ]
down like what do you think you're like
you didn't do anything it's just
you know so you
everyone played normal and it eventually
just felt normal
and uh yeah and it was a very small
school like not a lot of people so I
don't know like I didn't um
I think I really noticed when the show
started I think because then I started
getting attention my parents kept me
pretty normal kid Vibes for most of it I
went to I didn't miss school for
anything like Dad's on tour that's tough
[ __ ] you're not going you're going is
that right yeah no we didn't skip
out on Town and just to do like crazy
bougie stuff and he's not a very like
uh object-oriented person so he didn't
he doesn't wear like flashy it's funny
he doesn't wear flashy clothes it's
hilarious
he wears like free hats like you know
like someone will give him a hat for
free and that'll be his hat for the next
10 years yeah he came in very I'm
assuming I think it was a black hat and
maybe a blackjack and then someone gave
him that hat one day and yeah he'll wear
it till it falls apart he's uh he's that
guy he doesn't care about stuff he hears
about money but he cares about what
money represents which is like a wall
between him and that poverty he used to
experience so that's like whenever he
forgets to mention that so he comes off
like a dick bag all the time but when he
talks about like I love money what he's
really saying is like it got me out of
you know my shitty apartment in Harlem
with my mom and now I got her a house
and can afford her doctors so it's like
that's the real story it's just not as
cool to say for him sure but uh yeah so
he's not like I didn't have much of a
sparkly
until the show started then I got a
certain amount of attention then I was
like what's happening okay so show
started you said you were around 16. it
must have been I must be getting that
but up until then they're able to keep
you pretty distant from the whole kiss
phenomenon or or I mean I knew I mean
it's not like wasn't a secret it wasn't
deliberate it was just they were
determined that I have a normal
day-to-day life so like we talked about
and he'd show me stuff that he was doing
but I didn't go to Europe for four
months when I was eight you know I mean
like this and some you know musician
kids of Duty that he was like no no
you're going to school and you're
finishing school and when you're an
adult you ever you want so I think I
went I jumped on one leg of a tourism
when I was in my 20s I was gonna say
what's the first time what's the first I
went to shows no no I went to shows when
I was a baby like one off like if he
played in L.A go to the show
but uh I wouldn't like road trip with
him the first time you remember seeing
your dad do all that [ __ ] Blowfish no I
was too young I remember I have pictures
of me as like a little oh you're there
it's a baby baby oh okay yeah whenever
he's in town we go see him we're all
very closely knit so but uh yeah I think
they did a good job not making me
I didn't go to the part like my Mom and
Dad aren't very party
people which is weird to think also but
uh either they got out of the system
when they were younger
probably or they just didn't want to
push the kids into that so I'm kind of
grateful because I've met
I've met The Offspring of the people who
party with their parents and they're not
great yeah they're they're scary
so what's it like when it first starts
hitting you at 16 what are you getting
are you getting a lot of female
attention you're getting some I mean I
was a nerdy kid and I've always felt
like two I was tall right away so I was
but it wasn't like a cool athletic way
and like I don't know what to do with my
arms way because [ __ ]
knocking [ __ ] over and I'm like oh I
guess that's how far I go now that's
cool and then I like and then chest hair
comes and you're like no and you don't
know what's happening like I want to
look like you know Timberlake or
whatever whatever it was the
contemporary example
um
yeah so I uh felt really nerdy and
awkward and like I I used to see this is
honeydew stuff so I'll tell you like the
embarrassing [ __ ] so I don't know I used
to uh
sweat out of my armpits kind of like I'm
probably gonna do in this room but uh
like a lot is when I first did puberty
like I used to and it was only social
anxiety it wasn't like uh I didn't sweat
a lot when I ran track or whatever I
just was that right but like PE but when
you would work out or whatever
you wouldn't I had nervous sweats so I
used to like go to the bathroom a number
of times each class and like wipe and
like put my shirt under the dryer thing
and it got so bad that I like went to my
mom and I was like I can't stop like I
can't wear other type that's why I wear
black all the time now because I got
used to just doing because I couldn't
wear like white they would see like a
puddle because I was so nervous I didn't
know how to talk to anybody and uh my
mom brought me in and she says you know
you can get Botox shots in your armpits
and it'll stop you from sweating and I
went to the doctor and he's like yeah
you have like overactive glands I'm like
sick sexy that's cool girls love
overactive glands that sounds really hot
it's great I'm gonna be super popular so
I got like eight shots yeah super tall
dripping on people yeah disgusting
and it's like notice I can see like
beads on my forehead and I'm like
raising my hand in classes people are
like do you run here I'm like no I'm
just
can't talk to people I just don't know
how to talk to just terrified to answer
your question there's a woman there's a
there's a girl next to me and she looked
at me once and so now I have to go to
the bathroom and and uh [ __ ] dab so
Botox shots and it doesn't work for like
a number of months yeah okay it does
work it does work yeah but it hurts all
right well let's go back to what why are
you so nervous what was it about I don't
know school or
I'm a nerdy kid I don't know it wasn't
about girls this is about anything
anybody anybody your whole speaking
class no I've spoken like I think I run
my mouth when I'm nervous I like I
wasn't super quiet I was like I'll try
to be funny like and then it didn't work
and I would go I'm gonna go kill myself
it's I was that guy I think it's I think
probably a lot of comedians are like
that like the first attempt at comedy is
to
be you know Social Circle maneuvering of
some kind you try to be try to be funny
so that they like you can't be the cool
kids gotta be funny about to get your
ASB and I don't think I was funny I
wasn't funny I was just trying to be
funny failing and being awkward so yeah
and I talked to some classmates of mine
recently that I reconnected with and
they were like no we didn't think of you
that way like you're just a normal kid
it's mostly in your head but uh in my
head it was a huge deal and I had acne
like pretty severe severe right before
the show I think I wanted Accutane like
a year before the show offered us a show
lucky timing but I had like big
so I would be sweating with big and I
used to dress like white Hendrix like I
used to [ __ ] I just thought like I
had like I had like scarves and Beads
it's on the ship
that was on the show the [ __ ]
Photoshop right there dude
yeah don't Photoshop that too much do
you have uh did you have [ __ ] Fringe
oh yeah no no like wizard sleeves
sometimes yeah I would thrift stores
shop all the time because I loved I got
in the 70s music hard when I went to it
and the outfits too oh yeah I loved
white Jagger and I used to try to dress
like Morrison I wore the big belt and I
used to dress tons of beads and Steven
Tyler and all these guys and honestly
the old man when he was younger when he
took the makeup off used to he gave me
some of his old crap I was about to ask
you did he have anything still around
what's funny he and I had the same taste
so like he and I both liked the
generation before him so like British
Invasion which is what he grew up
listening to so I started liking that
too so he was like oh you got to see
this you gotta see this he started
that's some of the bonding but I just
used to dress
insane I wish I went to a school with a
uniform it would have saved me some
interesting photo photos
so it's on the show you'll see some
outfits if they ever go back and rerun
which they do occasionally do that
you'll see me like full bell bottoms and
like cowboy boots and then I'll be like
there's that Mr T level beads like
that's dude the amount of time I would
just I would just pick up whatever like
if I found something I'd just put it on
me
yeah let's start getting a horn
sideburns I did sideburns I thought that
was cool man I can't wait yeah
um but just growing up in front of a
camera what the [ __ ] is that like not
the whole time I mean before the show is
it a Monday to Friday deal wait how much
after weekends after school that's when
you're being shot school Friday and
weekends yeah but your parents are every
day right
um not it's it's whenever they're doing
something they're not sitting around
filming you when you're idle they're not
living in your home no okay but we got
pretty good at telling them when we were
gonna do something so at the beginning
they try to fake the whole thing because
that's cheaper for the production
company so they want to like fake the
entire thing they want to tell you what
to say and that's just like an easier
way to know they'll get the content they
want and me and my mom especially we're
just like I don't want to [ __ ] do
that that feels disgusting that feels
gross I don't I'm not an actor mom's
like I don't want to act as myself so no
yeah
um so I just told them like look if
you're gonna fake something just don't
tell me and at least my reaction will be
real like they did this thing I think I
talked about this on Christina's like
they towed my car
and they said like your car got towed
you parked in a red or whatever and I
panicked and then they were like no
we've got your cards fine
we just moved it to get the story point
you run down the street because I just
got free license bell bottoms yeah
you son of a [ __ ] no and I yeah I was
like you know so I'm giving you six
seven why are you [ __ ] giving a 16
year old kid anxiety in white Hendricks
outfit right here with everyone watching
about his car being towed that's just
[ __ ] up that's cool but I told them
not to tell me so they would have told
me if I hadn't told them not to tell me
I didn't want to act I'm not an actor I
don't want to be an actor so
they I didn't I didn't want to like Yep
this is my life and they're just like
it's total [ __ ] so I at least wanted
it to be a you know three-quarters
[ __ ] you know it was like uh rooted
in Truth at least at least at least what
I'm doing is sure like I'm reacting the
way I'm reacting for real at least I'm
not like pretend you're scared my car is
towed no I at least so I was like I'll
take the the uh weird moments of fear as
long as I don't have to pretend that I'm
living this lie so yeah it was an
interesting thought process for a
teenager to go through considering as a
teenager you're already kind of putting
masks on and trying them on
yeah and then masks all the way down
also you're growing up the child of two
famous people
and now you're on TV
yeah it was interesting what um looking
back on it what you would you say is the
biggest challenge of growing up
literally in front of the camera
um not uh the thing is like At first as
a teenager you love the good press like
or you love the good reactions because
this is like the beginning of social
media I think it's like Myspace days
maybe Facebook actually early Facebook
days I think I graduated in 07 high
school that's gonna be like Facebook
days anyway they you know you see people
your Facebook blows up and you kind of
go oh and then you're like now you're a
public profile you're not just like
here's my friends and family and then
you kind of go and I don't think there
was a template for this yet I don't
think the verified badge existed yet I
didn't think this whole ecosystem really
existed yet so
I was just like oh they love me and the
people are calling me cute and they like
girls are calling me cute and and older
women which was alarming I want to ask
about that because you're underage too
at the time yeah but I was tall and had
you know
you know this super inappropriate older
parent that was always on record being
super inappropriate not with me but in
general is vibe so yeah I got some
interesting but again it's like um
you know they say don't Google yourself
read your YouTube comments because if
you take the good one seriously then you
got to take the bad ones seriously so
the moment I got any hatred which of
course happens when you're on television
or anything I was devastated just like
and then I stopped Googling myself
entirely and haven't since then first
time I saw a Google page with my face on
it was at Christina's podcast is that
right she put it on the whole
neighborhood and I was like this is cool
I'm gonna talk to my therapist but this
feeling
I haven't seen this page with what I'm
up to in a long time oh that's the photo
they chose that's cool I'm gonna jump
off this [ __ ] bridge this is cool the
worst oh it's always like Nick Simmons
was a thing on this and they show you a
photo alert and you're kind of like
that's the one the algorithm was like
that's the one here's a question I'd
like to ask you because you're you're
perfect for this well
I know without even fame or anything
people have children and they just put
their kids on social media look at my
little kid here blah blah blah it's cute
whatever right yeah and then that kid's
gonna grow up one day and that kid may
want to be anonymous that kid may never
want to have a social media profile nor
would they ever have but you've already
put them on so a lot of people in your
world sort of know who they are and know
their world
for someone who's been in the even
without that TV show you're already the
son of these two people do you ever long
for and I can't say the goddamn word
right anonymity thank you brother I
remember this about you and the new
anonymity I remember this you've
mentioned this before this is a word you
always always do you long for it ever
yeah are you used to your world no no I
think I have a pretty good I mean I I uh
I'm glad I only got like this much Taste
of quote-unquote it's not fame but it's
like being a known person popular like
that much like I'm I'm a I'm a you know
if you're in the vague you know orbit of
dead and his stuff but dad's the one
who's actually famous I'm not actually
so I I my life is fairly normal I don't
get harassed I get like TMZ a couple
times a year
uh now and on the show it was like once
a week was it really because it was on
the air at the time so after the show it
calmed it really calmed down and
especially in this town there's like
bigger fish to fry so nobody really
gives a [ __ ] I mean it's I I can pretty
much go about my day not being bothered
most of the time I can always tell when
there's like news about one of us
because they'll bother me more and I'll
be like all right what did he say like
oh yeah oh you it comes was he on CNN
weighing in on topics he has no
expertise in whatsoever hi I play bass
and here's what I think of the Iran
Contra what the [ __ ] are you talking
about what do you why did they ask you
this well because I'm very well spoken
it's like this is the problem this is
the problem this is our problem like we
if a guy speaks with authority and has
some attention on it yeah we'll give him
like what he's talking about yeah
I don't don't listen to me I don't know
what the [ __ ] I'm talking about how do
you stay grounded taking advice from
Rogan on medicine he's a comedian shut
the [ __ ] he's just shocking [ __ ] he's
not well he said to do this don't listen
to him yeah he never he never said he
wasn't just a comedian he's always
telling he's always being like I talk a
lot of [ __ ] I'm a comedian yeah and
people were like well I thought you
weighed in on this on this debate he's
not part of the debate but I'm also
allowed he's just an opinion and be
completely out of my mind with it you're
allowed to say whatever the [ __ ] you
want yeah no one has to I I the
responsibility is to all of us and our
literacy in deciding what we want to at
the end of the day your choices are
yours man whatever whatever dad tells
you don't like it turn it off if my dad
tells you to do something and you do it
and it goes badly that's you you're not
even that's you
he was just talking I'll be like what
are his kids doing that's what I really
want to do the people who live with them
all that I don't even understand why
anyone gives a [ __ ] about what we were I
mean why the show happened because I you
know I love Zeppelin I don't give a [ __ ]
what pages kids are doing tonight I
don't really get it like I never watched
shows like that really and I'm grateful
it like allowed me to be financially
independent from a young age and it
opened a lot of doors for me so I'm
grateful that people give a [ __ ] but I
don't know why but it was on the air for
how many years like seven or eight or
something that's a big deal in your life
you're going from like almost a decade a
teenager learning how to dry and dress
right yeah and dress and you're also
10th 11th grade such an awkward time for
you all the time and then all the way
into early colleges while they were
filming me going to early manhood and
everything like [ __ ] what a transition
I don't think I had early manhood it's
different for your dad I mean I know
what whatever the age your mom too like
they're they're 10 years they're already
established and doing it you're you're
growing up there like that yeah no I
mean and you know Dad did it on purpose
I didn't know this thing was gonna go
before like he did abandon and he got I
was like 16 and they said hey you want
to be in a thing and I said okay and I
thought they'd film a season and get
bored of us because none of us do heroin
and it was not exciting like I don't
know what is exciting about us really
but uh it just kept going and people
really liked it and I kind of didn't
know what to do next I was gonna move to
New York and I couldn't because it got
renewed I was like the show got renewed
so
this is an opportunity and I they didn't
force me they were like hey if you don't
want to show anyone we're gonna have to
and then I was like but this is too I'm
I have money now and I have doors that
open for me and honestly that's
sometimes a blessing and a curse I think
at a young age I think when everyone
says yes to you at a young age I think
you you do things that you shouldn't
you're not qualified for I agree like I
think you should be told no in order to
get good at anything yes
I think if I wanted a stand-up career
they would have just get like oh go to
the Apollo tonight like they would have
just like while I was on the show
because they see dollar signs and they
don't they don't have that moment where
you're like oh he doesn't actually have
the skill set to do that right so I'm
really glad I didn't do like an album
because they wanted to they wanted to do
an album they wanted I did various
things that I shouldn't have done
because I was like
they were like you're great you're
awesome you're awesome you're great it's
great let's put it out the way you love
it and I was like cool okay and I don't
know enough to say no I need I should
probably get better at this before I
I should probably hone right no they're
just like let's do it how do where do
you how do you stay grounded how do you
say I don't know if I am well you sound
very grounded to me you sound very
reasonable you sound very people say
that a lot I don't know I think I'm
pretty paranoid
of in everything
well I mean I used to like people used
to be outside of when I lived at home as
a kid growing up on the show and as a
teenager there used to be like people
outside the gate sometimes like at night
oh just like fans waiting in their car
like they knew our address somehow and
uh I've had a number of alarming
experiences like that what's the most
scary one most terrible well there's the
most scary one that ever happened and
there's one that happened to me the most
scary one that ever happened before I
was born
uh my mom was pregnant with me and they
were in a New York hotel and I think
Dad's told this story uh and this woman
knocked on their hotel room door
and then mom answered she ran away and
then she came back and knocked again and
my dad answered and she said do you want
me to kick her in the stomach for you
whoa so if she had decided to just do it
I wouldn't be here
and uh he she just thought like oh he
doesn't want kids I'll take care of that
for him like I'll I'll take the bullet
because he's my hero and he yeah I love
him he's mine [ __ ] what happened to you
uh me I had a
there was like this crazy woman I guess
I mean I assume she's great she was just
making a lot of crazy noise and so my my
old my parents all plays they've moved
but my parents old place had like a call
box and then like you know a driveway
and then like there's space behind the
call box and like Shrubbery and then
like a gate so I I pulled up I was with
a friend in the passenger seat
um and I pulled up and it was raining
and this woman with a plastic bag over
her head
for the rain I think she had no umbrella
she ran up to my as I was kind of about
to roll it down to like punch in the
coach she ran to the window and kind of
like
slammed on the window like this and then
went like this and was like yeah and I
was like
yeah and it was raining and it was like
a horror movie and my friend in this
passion sheet was like Jesus Christ
and she didn't go away she was like
really trying to like come out here and
I don't know if she met me any harm but
she was clearly like the way she was
yelling was a little unhinged so either
it was
fanism or it was like mental illness and
so she only went away I typed 911 into
my phone and showed it to her and so she
was like Oh and it was like didn't even
occur to her that I was Disturbed even
though right yeah screaming and then she
jumped back in her car and I you know I
did fight or flight thing so I was
scared and then I was angry so I floored
it and like followed her car and I made
my friend write down the license number
and that was like his second time
hanging out with me
he's one of my best friends to this day
and he's like that was my crash course
on you and I'm like I'm amazed you're
still here man
damn so I've had a couple that was like
the scariest one but I just had people
like I am going to school and then
they're there and there's like
somebody's somebody with their kids with
cameras and again like we're not even
that I can't imagine what like Tom
Cruise's daily life is like because I'm
this big he's his his cultural footprint
and his Fame is I have like a teeny tiny
little corner of the media world that I
was in for a second
can you imagine what it's like to be
like famous famous I don't want it
that's why they have like these guys
walk around with bodyguards and stuff
it's just like a bodyguard no never I
mean yes
they're always hiding in the bushes
I really shouldn't say he does yeah he's
fine go kill him no he's but he's not
like as Vigilant because I think uh in
the day I think he did in the day I
think he was surrounded by staff and I
think
you do that when it's like a lot of
young people all at once just discovered
you and are trying to get at you
so anyway so I just like caught the that
was all for him that wasn't for me you
know what I mean that the crazy people
at the gate right sure so I live a
pretty normal life like I know
and I like my privacy now so that's my
paranoia there is nothing quite like the
smell of fresh baked bread coming out of
the oven especially on a chilly morning
during the holidays this is not a dream
my friend this can all be yours courtesy
of wild grain Wild Grain is the first
bake from Frozen box for artisanal bread
so you'll always have crowd-pleasing
bread rolls pastries pastas and more
right in your freezer while grain uses
only clean ingredients and utilizes a
slow sourdough fermentation process
that's healthier for you and tastes
better than anything you can find in a
grocery store every item bakes from
Frozen in 25 minutes or less this
holiday season while grain is featuring
delicious new limited time sweet treats
such as pumpkin cinnamon rolls orange
cranberry biscuits and chocolate
Avalanche croissants all you have to do
is sign up at walgreen.com Honeydew and
choose which type of box you want to
receive and how often it's easy to
rescue schedule skip or cancel I'm
telling you this is not some typical
frozen bread and pasta everything comes
out tasting so fresh and delicious it's
almost hard to believe you aren't
putting in the hours of work to get it
hungry already for a limited time you
can get 30 off the first box plus free
croissants in every box when you go to
walgreens.com honeydew to start your
subscription you heard me free
croissants in every box and thirty
dollars off your first box when you go
to wildgrain.com honeydew that's
wildgrain.com honeydew or you can use
promo code honey do a checkout the
struggles we face with our mental health
can Loom large over our lives maybe
yours maybe someone you love you've
tried everything or have you mind Bloom
is the solution for the next chapter in
mental health and well-being mind Bloom
is the leader in at home ketamine
therapy offering a combination of
science-backed Medicine with clinician
and guide support for people looking to
improve their mental health and
well-being mind Bloom can next patients
to license psychiatric clinicians to
help them achieve better outcomes with
lower cost greater convenience and an
artfully crafted experience to begin you
take mind Bloom's online assessment mind
Bloom will send you a kit in the mail
complete with medicine treatment
materials and tips for getting the most
out of your experience after only two
sessions 85 percent of Mind Bloom
clients reported improvements in
depression and 85 percent reported
improvements in anxiety it is time to
enter the next chapter of mental health
and well-being let mind Bloom guide you
let me say this real quick
I'm about to start week five of this I
took it for anxiety and I'm telling you
it is working for me that's what I'll
say if you're looking for something
different it's working for me a friend
of mine also took it she's already
starting to get off of her anti-anxiety
meds so
um it's been a wild experience it's been
super deep interesting
um you should be ready to deal with you
know some [ __ ] you whenever you're
working on your trauma you got to think
about your [ __ ] and this has been it's
been absolutely life-changing for real
alright so right now mindbloom is
offering my listeners 100 off your first
six session program when you sign up at
mindbloom.com Honeydew and you use the
promo code honey do a checkout you go to
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew for a hundred dollars off your
first six session program today that's
mindbloom.com honeydew promo code
honeydew now let's get back to the do
tell me about you said during the um
series your parents almost split oh yeah
um and it was real like this was the
part that everyone thinks we faked
ironically which is the most real season
of them all so tell me about it
um I touched on this a little with
Christina but this was the story I was
saving for you thank you because it was
probably the worst year
probably ever
um and funny to look back on which is
your brand that's it right that's it
can I just pause and say that I actually
like honeydew and I don't get the hate
yeah you can I like fruit cups and I
think it's fine what's the what is this
a thing that people hate it's not
everybody hates it I've explained it so
it's it's I don't think it's a hate
people leave it behind it's just uh
right people just don't be the
blueberries yeah strawberries
blueberries was this a bit that you were
doing it all came about from me sitting
in a diner one night I'm eating I eat
the fruit cup I even eat the shitty red
grape I like green grapes but I hate the
[ __ ] red one I don't like red grapes
no I don't care I'm out of here but I am
and I leave the Honeydew just because I
just don't [ __ ] with it it's just like
yeah it's never been like yeah I like
cantaloupe it doesn't even have the bite
of cantaloupe okay and as I leave I see
it everywhere on the tables and I'm like
it's interesting it's a it's a it's a
perfectly good fruit that most people
leave behind toss aside and then that's
when it dawned on me that that's what I
am in life I will say fair enough like
that's not what you are that's what I am
people throw me away so many [ __ ]
times I don't think anyone who has a
logo on the wall over again
upside down that's right I leaned into
that [ __ ] how do you think the rest of
us do it but people are like oh rap
bacon around them if you gotta wrap
bacon around here wait wait
honeydew yeah people do some Southern
[ __ ] I don't know people hit me up like
if you do this with it I'm like well if
you wrap bacon around anything almost
okay sorry I didn't mean to that girl
all good so I was like thinking about
it's like this food that's the meme is
and I was like I ate it this morning
anyway
um so I had a whole fruit cup and no
honey doing I had strawberries I don't
even like raspberries they took notes
they took not like raspberries I don't
like to pee in that [ __ ]
oh like the fruit I sound like I don't
like that pee in there it's not like
real rage in your eyes it was like a
real real resentment for that that's
that beer raspberry [ __ ] out of here
anybody pronounces the pizza it's like a
non-flashbox
[ __ ] raspberries
June 7th 1991. I'll never forget 91 that
pee in raspberry
I bet you I was days away from
graduating [ __ ] raspberry anyway I
was
stupid
um
yeah see that's what it'd be like if I
tried stand up [ __ ] Seinfeld [ __ ]
like that so so uh anyway the the show
what was I talking about oh yeah the
parents oh yeah oh you know the biggest
thing that happened to me so they uh so
dad had this image of like being a kind
of delete you know a degenerate kind of
groupie Hound but the whole time he was
like on record being that dude at home
he was not like that and he was on the
show being super wholesome dad guy and
the the part the part that nobody gets
is that he really was a good dad and is
like he's very attentive very
affectionate very present very even like
the as much as he's on tour when he's
home he's home and we would call him all
the time so it was like there was this
whole vibe of like my parents were
perfect like I just hit the jackpot
there is like most people I knew had
some trouble at home of some kind
because that's normal
and I was just the one that didn't like
every you know I had friends from every
Stripes every economic background and
the Sons and Daughters of people had the
family [ __ ] and like my best friend
growing up was our housekeeper's name is
Millie and she also like we call like
house manager because she also like
babysat us and like hung out well she
was just like she was the second mom she
was she raised me basically and her her
son Walter was like my best friend
growing up so I'd stay over at her house
like every other night and even he like
I saw them she had problems with the dad
she everyone had something and so I was
like wow I'm just the rare exception to
the rule also my parents don't fight
they don't like nothing it was just and
they're in the animal industry which is
a hard thing to pull off too yeah two
people in it not just one person because
it attracts [ __ ] insane people yeah
so uh and makes people insane
so uh yeah so I was just like wow what a
jackpot not only is my life so nice but
my parents get along my family all gets
along no one calls each other names no
one says you [ __ ] you're like never
like our disagreements we would talk it
out and they would be rare and it's like
Dad was always like what can we complain
about another day above ground Life's
good
it was non-stop like okay my biggest
drama ever was like you hit your sister
when you were five and now you're
grounded it's like nothing nothing bad
ever happened to us and then uh it turns
out Not only was he flandering he had
been doing it since like after my sister
was born up until that point which is
what year was your sister ah nice oh
[ __ ] math uh math on a microphone 90 90
90s she's 30.
so that year and uh so math anxiety do
you ever have watch anxiety like math or
watch it when you have I can do math
perfectly good but if someone's watching
me do it I turn into an eighth grader
who hasn't learned his times tables yet
yeah yeah exactly
I have I go what time is it I go I just
kind of and then when they walk away I
go I got it I got it it's five minutes
they're like dude it's telling time you
should have been able to do that
instantly I go but you were looking and
I oh so
anyway that's what just happened so
she's 30. I'm 33. and uh so for yeah so
20 years yeah more and Only onto like as
far as I know tour it was like they were
throwing themselves at him or whatever
and he was saying yes and how did this
all come out I think Mom discovered like
emails or something or like arrangements
or something she you know somebody or
somebody reached out to her like some
woman with a bone to pick I think
reached out to her I didn't go into the
details because I didn't want to know
like I didn't really want to know about
his whole schtick and I was well into
never Googling us
so you know I think Mom took me aside
and like all right so here's what's
going on and she's a tough so she took
me aside like that she's like all right
so listen
with that tone voice and I was like cool
we're gonna go to the movies your dad's
cheating me and I kind of record scratch
moment
and the shows just got renewed and we're
about to do in the season so I was like
what do we do and we have like we go oh
let's meet with a producer and producer
is guy named Adam he's really nice to us
he was like a pal he wasn't like shady
Hollywood producer we were lucky enough
to like we liked the people that
produced the show so they weren't like
[ __ ]
and he was like yeah if you don't want
to address on the show we don't we won't
address it and my mom just stood up and
just said like [ __ ] that I want to
address all of it let's go she goes if
TMZ is gonna get this I want to put it
out myself like I'd rather nobody get
the money for my scoop like I'd rather
just air my dirty laundry on my own
terms
and not let somebody else you know
expose me I'll [ __ ] expose me and uh
and I was like wow we're doing this so
there was a whole year of like
an odyssey of various like her her
staying in hotel sometimes is that right
her coming back and then working working
on it
them working on like uh and so what she
told me after the fact they're married
now they got married after this
so they were never they were not married
dad was very on record about being
against marriage like in as a principal
he was like it's silly we shouldn't
invite lawyers into this like it's none
of their business what you do every day
should be a choice really he was like
trying to have one foot out the door
kind of thing it was like mostly what it
was about probably he made some good
arguments but
you know I do think there's something to
be said about like why are you inviting
lawyers into your life into your
relationships there is something there
but you know his real motivation was
like he was he never pictured himself in
this situation I was definitely an
accident I always is that right oh
definitely oh for sure we talk openly
about it yeah oh I didn't know easily
it's it's one it's a running joke at
Christmas it's it's uh I I always saying
I'm your favorite mistake to him
um
how are you a mistake because he wasn't
trying to have kids he just was
irresponsible he was having fun with
your mom and that's great that's cool
way to say it and the yeah I'm gonna
said it way worse awesome more therapy
so the
cool way to cool way to do that so
he was no Mom Mom's very uh
she was like oh yeah he didn't want kids
at all and then he found out you were a
boy and he was like oh interesting a
mini me and then he was kind of on board
after that what about your sister was
that she was on purpose once she had one
kid he was like yeah let's do it again
yeah like he was stoked on being a dad
but he didn't know he wanted that he was
very like
I'm a nomad I'm a rolling stone I don't
really
so she so he your mom forced him to own
up because she had no she didn't she she
did this thing where she's like look uh
I'm ready I'm having a baby you can be
as involved as you want I'm sorry I mean
the cheating oh sorry yeah so did and he
admitted it he came clean and they were
immediately you know what's funny is
like it's hard to be mad at him because
for all his uh you know he's got a big
personality and ego he does this thing
which
I think was probably a good example on
me as a kid where he like when he knows
he's wrong he'll say it so he'll go like
he'll he'll say like I stand corrected
when you prove him wrong about something
he just talked about and I go like
that's fairly big of somebody because
nobody does that like nobody's like yeah
you're right everyone goes like well
it's the way you said it like they'll
just you know fight he'll immediately go
like oh never mind I was wrong
so when we found out he's like yep I was
being an [ __ ] like he just immediate
he didn't fight really uh he talked to
you about it I think there were some
heated discussions between them but when
he talked to me about he's like yep I'm
men are idiots I'm beating I'm being an
idiot or your mom deserves better than
this
and I was just like I really wish you
were meaner about this so I could yell
at you but I can't because you're saying
what I want to say
so I just kind of like felt kind of kind
of impotent kind of powerless to do
anything because he was like he knew
and he was like yeah I was being an
idiot
and what did that do to you
I just I numbed it out I think after the
fact I did a lot of work on it but I
think at the time I was just like avoid
out of sight out of mind try not to
think about it be there for mom as much
as I can but I don't want to hear
details I want to be numb I don't want
to look at it
I never gave an opinion I didn't watch
the show like I still haven't seen I've
seen maybe two or three episodes of the
show to this day because I probably
won't watch this because it's like uh
it's listening your own voice recorded
you know it's like uh
what are the two options here I'm gonna
love it and become a total narcissist or
I'm gonna hate it and get depressed it's
like there's no winning I'd rather just
be blissfully ignorant so didn't watch
the show from the very beginning and now
I was like I'm really not watching the
show now and is that also because
there's more conversation about this
stuff between your mom and dad to camera
to each other that you're privy to oh
yeah and I was there and there's a lot
of like uh and this stuff that obviously
they didn't get everything there's a lot
sure of real [ __ ] behind the scenes but
um
yeah my mom was very adamant she's like
if I'm gonna be in the press for this I
want to do it and I leave you know what
like
write that check like if I'm gonna like
go through this horrible horrible
experience I'm gonna be the one to break
the news to everybody and talk about it
on my terms with I'm gonna go into the
edit Bay and edit the way I like it and
dad was like sure okay sure fine and
then the real culmination of the story
is
my mom kind of gave him this
it's kind of like the opposite of an
ultimatum she kind of said like look I
still love you we have kids together the
kids are grown so we could separate and
it would be probably be fine
so she goes basically like all I want to
do is like punish you for what you did I
really am angry and like so marry me
I'm getting to that I'm getting to that
so she's like uh
you know she's like I I hate that you
didn't tell me mostly I'm hey I hate you
for the lying because it wasn't like he
was having
other families and relationships right
it was groupy Behavior it was so she's
like it's not that I don't get what
you're getting out of this it's
validation and hooking up and it's guy
[ __ ] it's I just wish you hadn't lied to
me about it if that's what you wanted
you should have just told me you don't
think people have wanted to date me over
the years like she's like I could have
been all their respect and finding my
situation yeah sure she's like and I
still could so you like the the lie was
disrespectful on a number of levels
because she's like I could have been
you're just keeping me here at home
while you're having fun I could have
been having fun I could have met
somebody and like you just wasted my
time so she said but here's the thing I
still love you and that's not going away
no matter how mad I am at you for this
so here's the deal the deal is
we separate and I don't talk bad about
you in the Press I'm not gonna sue you
I'm not going to take half your [ __ ]
I've got my I'm good I have money I'm
gonna be fine and we'll go you know the
Press ask will be like no we're friends
everything's fine and we'll just give
them nothing to talk about and I'm not
gonna badmouth you and your Empire is
secure
or you can knuckle down and marry me and
do the real do it for real this time and
then I get all your passwords
and uh to everything you own email and
phone and everything and I get to check
whenever I feel like it
and so and she was like I was like why
didn't you want to like actually get
your revenge and she goes if I had
threatened him with anything and he
stayed I would have never known why he
stayed was it fear of consequences or
was it because he actually loved me
right never would have I had to take
great she had to take the consequences
off the table if she really wanted to
know how he felt she goes here's a free
pass go be groupie guy we'll be friends
we'll hang out we're gonna have a great
relationship it'll be fine no
consequences to you or you can marry me
which one do you actually want
because I don't want you to feel trapped
here that's not fun for me I don't want
to you to be here because oh if I don't
she'll do this and that and the other
make a real choice in a vacuum and I
want to see what you actually want to do
so then he proposed and he proposed on
the air The Producers were like way it
was on the beach or something which is
his least favorite [ __ ] place he's
stupid hair is blowing in the wind he's
got like this open color he's wearing
like cowboy boots and he's like I
[ __ ] hate this he hates wind because
it like messes up his hair he's just he
gets on winning he goes like Oh my God
and he's just like and it's like the
silliest looking proposal ever and they
were they just did like telescopic lens
from sure they didn't like
and they had mics on so they filmed the
whole thing and he's been as far as we
know pretty much great since then that
was like 2011 I think October okay so
over 10 years yeah how did your mom
build trust back up again yeah she's in
a row with him for a little bit or she's
like sometimes if you're going to be
sometimes she does no but she's like I
don't trust you [ __ ] let me verify
whenever I feel like it and he's like
sure fine good great did you ever see
him cry you ever see your father cry
yeah mostly up sad movies he shut when
it comes to real [ __ ] he like he goes
inward even during that yeah I saw tears
um I think I saw him get fighting back
mistiness I saw mom crying a number of
times yeah but she's like she's like
this tough she like cry she like gets
the cry over with she's one of these but
she goes like
okay I'm good and she just like she gets
it out real quick and then she just
moves the [ __ ] on and goes right to
anger and she's like you know they're
both like on their own from a young age
so they were just like she was a child
of like I think eight siblings and she
just like moved to the US at like 14.
Newfoundland Canada she was like a
beauty queen in Canada for a while she
was like Miss Ottawa and then she moved
to the stage she's like peace I'm out
started a bar before she was old enough
to drink really fake ID and [ __ ]
Shannon's Bar
and then uh yeah and then Hef and then
they met on the front porch of the
Mansion at a party your dad I swear your
dad mom yeah and again people always see
this and they're like how did you not
see this coming he's like you weren't
there dude you didn't see this guy he is
a
really good father and like very devoted
kind of guy I didn't knock over a thing
that's okay he's like a devoted like
Papa kind of guy so when you experience
him 90 of the time that way and then you
see him in interviews acting a fool you
go oh that's
that's the job like he's acting a fool
and that's the game and it's a character
and it is but he's you know famous since
you're 25 you believe your character
after a while and you kind of like the
attention and uh yeah because you get it
acting he's done on so many different my
mom's not an idiot she's like you know
she's like I know what you guys get out
of this she's like I know what groupies
does for it makes you feel like you're a
God or something like you how many times
have groupies [ __ ] over like really
powerful people and by [ __ ] up I mean
they're decision making [ __ ] them over
like
Schwarzenegger and about all these
people like you feel like you're king of
the world when people desire you
right so it's not like she didn't get it
her thing that made her not just leave I
think was he didn't have another main he
didn't have like another girlfriend in
another house until someone with another
family it was just he was getting his
validation kicks and it still really
hurt her I'm not trying to minimize that
but I think that was the even the reason
she was even open to talking to he
didn't love someone else
he truly did someone else he had no uh
nothing resembling their relationship
anywhere else and I I'm sure we've all
heard of these guys who have done that
they have like the house down the street
yeah yeah after that people come on here
and tell me they had a whole lot of
family somewhere else I think that would
have been
absolutely and she thought this was a
deal record but yeah the ultimatum was
the thing which I've never heard of
someone do before where they go no
you're gonna be fine either way you'll
be fine now choose
I thought it was kind of cool of her and
pretty more patience than I would have
had probably in that situation I was
gonna just about to ask you like what uh
curious what you did you ever have a
one-on-one with your dad about this
stuff a number of times yeah I mean he
he just he says the same things all the
time he's like men are children we're
idiots like we you know we chase this
dream we're morons he says like men
shouldn't be considered adults until
they're 45 like he always says [ __ ] like
that and I'm kind of go like yeah kinda
a little bit a lot of us especially in
Hollywood I think I think I had a number
of
like missed development landmarks
because of the show probably like I
don't think I grew up really until like
29 28 probably because I just I always
felt like a kid
I just never really felt fully developed
and I think my judgment wasn't very good
like wasn't as good as it should have
been at like 25
yeah just various things I was like I
just definitely still felt like a
teenager I think
TV shows keep you there
like mentally
so yeah and how do you feel about your
parents relationship now they're good
right oh they're great he's and he's
like extra doting now because I think he
has that oh I almost lost this feeling
yeah and he's like this I'm gonna die
with this person so he's like
she's like because she's still the same
like ass kicking person she always was
she always goes like
will you stop [ __ ] chewing and then
he'll turn to me and goes isn't she
great
she goes she
she goes sometimes I want to [ __ ]
murder you and he and she goes he goes
there's no one like her there's nobody
can I go she just said she wanted to
kill you he goes I know
isn't that awesome like he's just like
doting actually here it's a text from
recently
do you want does this bother you not at
all uh I should have put this in
airplane mode but I just screenshotted
this stupid yesterday she was uh
they're watching like Dateline NBC and
they were like
the whole thing was like someone got
choked to death and
she sent me this photo of him like on
the floor
with like Furniture knocked over and she
said I was practicing how to choke out
your father but it didn't work it was on
Dateline and we're like what and then
Dad goes yeah she was practicing how to
kill me by choking me she made me get on
the ground she climbed on top and put
her legs over my arms and put her hands
on my neck but I tipped her over
and I was like what guys this is not a
good idea she goes we saw it on Dateline
how old are they and the cop said it's
one way you wouldn't be able to tell if
she was if you smothered somebody so we
were trying to test it I go are you
[ __ ] this is jackass [ __ ] this is
like you're gonna die
that's what they're doing at home so I
said she said so I said why when she
didn't she wrap her legs around his head
and pulled him back and just tipped him
over your dad thought because he was
much heavier so he tried it and dead can
get out of it so don't worry he got out
of it she and he called he I went over
there and he's like no she really choked
me like a lot like she I was like
pressed on my windpipe and I was like
cool
great
good for you guys
that's good I mean man a Hollywood
[ __ ] marriage that lasts that long
it's because they don't act like they're
not really a Hollywood marriage at home
they're not they're like they're big
dorks in footie pajamas it's just the uh
you know he's addicted to he has one
addiction he'd never did drugs or
anything he has one addiction and that's
like attention I think and uh you know
that feeling he gets on whatever and
think about it if you were
22 and then that happened how [ __ ]
crazy would you be I'd be in someone to
[ __ ] my dick off I had eight I would
have had AIDS five six times yeah I'd be
the king of AIDS they call me and eight
squared but like no it's oh God think
about the state of mind to 22. remember
that I can't even if you got attention
in school now multiply that by 10
million
and I'm a little crazy from the amount
that I experienced this 16. I can't even
imagine how all these guys are eccentric
I was talking to Tom has this bit about
how like McConaughey and all these guys
are really weird people like whenever
they make social I mean Johnny Depp made
an Instagram and he like they're weird
they don't talk normal they speak with
this weird affectation and they second
Garth Brooks the whole thing that Garth
is Dad like that's he's weird because
how could you not be you don't have a
real conversation with anyone ever for
like 40 years you know everyone knows
your name and it's like this weird
second guessing and seeing yourself
through their eyes you go insane you
become an eccentric weirdo I think yeah
humans were not meant to handle that
level of attention but also for him to
avoid
alcohol drugs in a rock and and one I
think it was like a point of Pride for
him though but I mean one of the biggest
rock and roll bands in the world through
the 60s 70s 80s I mean Jesus Christ the
drugs that must have been it wasn't it
wasn't temptedness he was disgusted by
it from the top yeah so it wasn't like
he resisted Temptation he was like uh
like he never liked it he never liked
the look he liked being articulate he
doesn't like feeling like he's not going
to say the cleverest thing right uh
which he rarely does
yeah oh he'll do that in like a
restaurant yeah
you know have you heard sagura's bit
where he's like his dad at like a
restaurant and he goes the the waiter is
Asian and he goes how weird are you
about to be with him yeah what are you
about to say and he goes like you
Chinese and you go what does that have
to do
with anything he goes like no I'm crying
he goes oh I was in Vietnam
again what the [ __ ] he's like what I'm
just making conversation it's like
there's a certain generation and then
you add Fame to that and you get real
weird and he was like what everyone's so
sensitive I go no you're [ __ ] weird
bro you're weird that's why they're
looking at you weird because you're
strange
but I love him he's great everybody's
good everybody's on solid footing I see
him all the time we hang out yeah you
guys came to the comedy show together oh
yeah which also I wanted to say thank
you for that because thanks for letting
us in pulling all the ego and and names
and titles and what everybody does out
of this I love when dads and Sons come
to my shows together man oh that's nice
I was gonna say you're thanking me for
coming to your show is kind of weird
when I when I do the meet and greets and
they come up and it's like yes my dad I
brought I'm like oh
so it was really nice to see what's your
relationship together he's dead I mean
what was the you just never got a chance
sir
he died when I was 16. so I didn't
really get to do I I did get to go with
him though I will say this I got to go
see the Beastie Boys and Run DMC to on
it together forever tour when I was like
14 because he took us to that nice so I
got that one that memory it's good then
that's it but I mean you it's just not
you're talking to me about the trauma of
being on a show when I was 16. you went
through more [ __ ] right there I mean
that's yeah but I didn't have to if I
would have had a camera no you were
financially people were mean to me on
Twitter
who the [ __ ] come on what am I
complaining about I have nothing to
complain about I have a great day well
you I hear you it's all relative man
like you're right about that my point of
view is I'm paranoid about think but
like you know there's people that are
gay like it's kind of reasonable to be a
little paranoid so I I have no
complaints my life's great like I have a
really good life and mostly my problem
is like feeling kind of guilty for
having such a good life because I didn't
earn it I was born into it and even if I
make my own strides I still had a huge
leg up from day one so me and Christina
was talking about like the get the
liberal guilt of all that the kind of
like
feeling like [ __ ] for being lucky and
you know my therapist always just goes
like yeah but that's kind of selfish too
to feel like [ __ ] it's like you're
you're it's still a narcissistic spiral
it's just a negative one well I'll still
feel like wondering about your own you
know that exists on both ends of the
spectrum you can feel like [ __ ] for
being lucky you also feel like [ __ ] for
being unlucky yeah
it's selfish to like feel like [ __ ] for
being lucky and not enjoy being lucky
because like how many people the other
guys give it to me then like don't why
are you wasting it with this navel
gazing nonsense like so I just try to
just don't be an [ __ ]
and you know don't be a like a silly
Silver Spoon [ __ ] rocking around
thinking I'm thinking I've also seen
enough examples of that too that's
definitely true my nightmare is like
I've met a couple of these people and I
won't name names but
like some Sons and Daughters ever really
think that they're [ __ ] hot [ __ ]
because of nothing they did right and uh
that's a Nightmare knife so I think I
actively try to avoid being that dude I
hope I'm successful at avoiding being
that dude
because uh that dude sucks and and
there's a lot there's a lot of them all
right this is uh your first time here
and I I told you before we started at
the end I was going to ask you advice
you give to your 16 year old self so I'm
sorry I ramble I feel like I rambled too
much you didn't ramble this is what
you're supposed to do it's your episode
can you imagine if I just talked the
whole time what [ __ ] kind of episode
with your professional talker probably
more more cohesive I am a professional
talker no one's ever said
that's what you do for a living I feel
like it'd probably be a better episode
that's gonna be my new credit there was
some baritone kid on Sickler's Pockets
rambling about his [ __ ] non-problems
couldn't even get I [ __ ] didn't seem
like a professional talker to me I
couldn't even come in with a bit you
just like this kid just kept it Non-Stop
kid I'm 33 it's [ __ ] uh advice to my
16 year old self
um
yeah I don't Google yourself even sooner
like don't uh listen stop right there
for a moment please that's great advice
now one person has come on and talked
about the use of Technology you don't
don't talk about it you're a younger
think about the type of person I mean do
you know anyone that leaves like
negative YouTube comments for fun no I
don't know a single per like who are
these people right so I think if you
you can't read that [ __ ] because it's
like these are not this is not life
like this is this is somebody's quick
trigger finger response you can't I mean
that sits with you if you read it
literally don't what's that old uh I
think it's an Andy Warhol quote don't
read what they write about you just
measure it in inches
and uh she's like don't don't read about
yourself and don't Naval gaze
about yourself don't everyone else is
doing the same thing about themselves
just go about your day don't read uh
yeah don't don't like seek out your how
you appear in other people's eyes I
think that's great yeah
um dude thank you very much for coming
on thanks thanks for having me man I'm a
big fan will you um please promote
whatever you can yeah
I'm uh I'm on Instagram most of the time
I really I barely [ __ ] with Twitter if I
start to launch a thing under my own
name I'll I'll tweet it so both
platforms it's Nick T Simmons
um that's pretty much all I do I don't
read Twitter I I just I post on
Instagram now and then so go there I
will I'll launch something at some point
uh but I've been enjoying the Privacy so
I think I'm gonna keep that going for a
minute the anonymity but if you want to
see what I'm kind of yeah anime you did
it I think I got a nail dig I got it but
yeah I enjoy uh my kind of quiet life
and I've been doing this secret thing
that's been really fulfilling so I'm
gonna keep that going for a little while
but if I decide to release it it'll be
on there so great or I'll try to come
back here if you'll have me please I
will for sure yeah thank you dude thank
you for coming and thank you all as
always uh Ryan sickler on all social
media Ryan sickler.com we'll talk to
y'all next week
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]